ok bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
questo video sono fatti jpg siamo su
cazzo si chiama vostro gioco di merda è
piede e oggi siamo su qualcuno la voglia
di spiegarmi perché un pene al posto del
naso
ok comunque ragazzi siamo su happy happy
porca [ __ ] come cazzo si chiama happy
lpl ma l'inizio ha finora mi viene in
mente ma strana accettato c'è il bene
che fa su e giù quando salto se impegni
a parte è una cosa che succede cosa ho
fatto a posso cambiarla telecamere che
figo sono morto a sé tocco i fantasmi
muoio per te è meglio saperlo comunque
ragazzi è un gioco incredibilmente non
senso credo perché a giudicare dalle
dalle pene che ho al posto del naso mi
sembra che sia così cosa devo fare qua
the bush of jump in testa air france
press ha la madonna già preso web sono
un fenomeno ragazze deve uscire di qua
quindi primo assalto per la madonna che
fiducia mi sento uno è tanto soste
scarpe che sono troppo esageratamente
fashion altro che osta ragazzi queste
sono scarpe cazzo cioè una sorta di
super mario sono molto più piedi è una
cosa mi rappresenta
cos'è oh mio dio sono stato ucciso laden
degli occhi e così è la vita ragazzi un
giorno viviamo all'altro giorno veniamo
cit perché ci sono degli occhi cosa è
caduto un occhio la madonna posso
giocare a calcio con gli occhi ma che
figo guardavo guardo ronaldigno guardano
mamma no non ci credo
che è il della madonna fa comunque
ragazzi a parte sta roba e gli occhi che
si suicidano dovrebbe essere un gioco
tibro supermario sono molto più cazzo
possono io che sono checa oppure di è
più difficile di quanto pensassi
comunque è un platform jaurès di thule
vita.it objects book in house cioè io
posso ad evitare con lo spock in house
si vuol dire no no state lontani
state lontani o mio dio i feticisti via
[ __ ] giocate e c'è un naso che mi
sta smoccolando in testa è ovvio c'è
amico mio io ti consiglierei dei
fazzoletti però le caccole sono
bellissime senti fratello aveva ucciso
un piede qual è il senso di sta roba
spiegatelo vi prego no madonna ma dove
l'hanno
cosa ho appena come mi sono salvato non
lo so neanch'io perché se tipo
galleggiando niente sono morto come un
idiota
allora carminati che devo prendere
dimestichezza coi joystiq che è molto
più figo così fa chi ha ridonato di
merda
io io ho chinasi ragazzi non so perché
riesce la fobia di scherzi stronzo cd mi
guarda un professional cosa dovrebbe
essere un giorno zia tuttavia posso
farmi un bagno con te o ti incazzi sono
tre cose di cui ho bisogno per fare la
mia zuppa un bunker che non so che cosa
sia una scura di quelle che ti ri
proprio col culo e per finire un occhio
perfetto allora gli occhi sa dove
trovarli la scorreggia posso farla
comando è manca il booker ragazzi che
cazzo è un bucato era stato il fiuto del
mio pene naso non mi delude mai troppo
un'altra mano rega che cos'è questo
gianpi mid air tua lei sa vertical boss
non ho capito un cazzo ma va bene fare
gare perfetto ho trovato la scorreggia
non perché ragazzi amo questo gioco è la
cosa più bella che abbia mai visto in
tutta la mia vita scarta zio che cazzo
zio bobby sei tu zio bobby perché sono
stato appena ucciso lo zio bobby sto
stronzo ascolta frate ho trovato un
altro cose intanto
voi avete giocato a supermario fino ad
oggi avete sbagliato tutto è una roba
invece va bene non ho capito cosa devo
trovare ma va bene lo stesso il mio pene
può prendere le cose cioè una roba oh
mio dio mio dio ma vedendo gli
innovativi meno prima questo che cazzo
ne sapevo io che potevo prendere le cose
allora ciò la palla cecio l'occhio
attento regalo perfetto adesso fisco
regione ecco chi manca un bugiardo e che
cos'è un blogger che cazzo è successo
zio bob no no no il pezzo di merda di un
naso chimica ti smoke all in faccia
ragazzi nutrita più più bella in un
videogioco posso sorride raccomando
andate che roba qualcuno ha voglia di
spiegarmi questa cosa va beh e bello
sapere che ci sono certi videogiochi che
ti lasciano il segno dentro presse
raitre ho trovato un altro potere
ragazzi c'è una roba cosa cazzo sono
diventato o mio dio sono ten singh non
aveva trovato il superpotere del secolo
terminati adesso posso andare là sopra
credo più o meno è impazzito cazzo è la
roba vabbè mi è impazzito personaggio
avete pazienza adesso posso scorreggiare
attorno ai nemici è fantastico è stata
la cosa più bella che abbia mai fatto
belle ragazze
deve solo video sono fa vj ci siamo su
ad es
endless shameless millionaire che
presidente sarebbe un gioco allora
niente tipo chi vuol essere milionario a
quello con gerry di tom e jerry primi
venti ragazzi sarebbe la stessa cosa
quindi si vincono dei soldi però diciamo
che la versione un pochettino più
violenta perché è praticamente
invece di farti le domande bisogna
afferrare i soldi con la mano la
difficoltà sta nel fatto che c'è una
ghigliottina che ti taglia la mano
quindi devo riuscire a prendere la
banconota prima che mi tagli il braccio
perché se no vedo un attimino come la
situazione tipo bene bene
e stato bello braccio destro perso usa
il sinistro è ovvio
va bè ragazzi usiamo a sinistra
nawalapitiya due possibilità perché ho
due braccia adesso eccomi taglio anche
l'altra quindi col cazzo che che riesco
a vinci niente adesso le gambe ma niente
le gambe allora ciò due possibilità
ragazzi perciò anche l'altro braccio
fortunatamente si siano ragazzi che
abbiate capito come funziona spero
perché non ho voglia di rivederlo
sinceramente credo di riuscire a passare
star e allora io non so se voi lo
fareste mai ragazzi a un certo punto per
prendere dei soldi vabbè io ci provo
piano piano preso vabbè ma la sinistra
amado chiudere il braccio a ok di melo
che cazzo ne so però che afferrasse in
automatico e col pugno unidas tra è la
volevo picchiare non ci sono riuscito a
kami attimo preso preso già fatta che è
un dollaro ci siamo ragazzi siamo a 2
dollari
dobbiamo arrivare a 500.000 sono un
disastro ok dollari vai carico carico
opachi
sbagliato non ho fatto possono che avere
inizio già possiamo fare ritroviamo dove
basta fare i [ __ ]
ci provò sul serio in chiave un po
sudato freddo giuro 5 dollari dai già
posto il bene che ti fotte perché a
volte sbaglia c'è cambia proprio
velocità a cazzo preso 5 dollari ragazzi
possiamo comprarci la merenda 10 dall
aver fine la farei mai questa cosa
neanche per le funzioni le unghie zio
che c'è j si ok ok 10 dollari
non ce la farò mai ragazzi sappiatelo
però vabbè cazzo preso ok 20 20 non
capisco il ritmo è difficilissimo
veramente c'è un certo punto diventi
incasinatissimo ok ragazzi sto veramente
sto andando a casa lei e rifredi dai già
facciamo se macerata cazzo sono un
fenomeno è ormai se cose ma tono meno
meno male che ho sbagliato ad andare
avanti almeno meno male poi e poi ad
affari non è successo niente perfetto
botta di culo siamo mille ragazzi ce la
possiamo fare adesso iniziano a vedersi
i soldati veri ce la posso fare ma
chiedere l'aiuto del pubblico telefonata
a casa non lo so qualsiasi cosa
magari non c'è non ce la posso fare un
rock the fucking
parchi ai ragazzi 5 fottuti mi lascia
potrò fare perché intanto non lo afferra
malizia quadrato 1688 dollari è una roba
indecente ho rischiato di perdere la
mano pronto quante volte mi sono io
stato troppo stavolta lo ammetto ma ben
10.000 non so se le ultime riuscito a
farle fatto legami che hanno solo un
freno di dico una cosa io questo gioco
l'avevo provato tanto tempo fa giusto
per capire com'era ed ero morto non
sapete quante cazzo io non so come sto
farlo noi neri come sia possibile che ho
adesso ci stia riuscendo in possesso rdo
ma porca [ __ ] ma dai
no no sono io per donare che annuncia
farò mai più lo so già le perdo tutte e
due stavolta vede braccio no no
perché non su di sé perché senti idiota
inutile fai così col braccio se un
deficiente cioè non ha senso se sto
aprendo la testa di sto tizio piuttosto
dare gavi premi supplico ho avuto un
infarto vi giuro come è possibile non mi
sono mosso ma l'inizio come possibile
poi termina no dai regali devono
iniziare mi gira non troppo le balle dai
con un braccio non saprò mai vip regia è
anche il sinistro non solo mancino io
[ __ ] no no no se si pigia pigia
piston che hai detto bene ok può donare
al digiuno sto sudando il sangue
veramente sto male dai 100 mm con un
braccio solo non ce la farò mai rega c'è
una cosa si cela polso fottutamente fare
è l'ultimo podio quebec poi è sempre un
dollaro come cazzo il possesso continua
a prendere un dollaro da un'ora e mezza
eppure non lo so perché ma vale di più
ragazzi sono legate al momento più
importante della nostra vita o la va o
la spacca
ola ola tagli anzi siamo arrivati fin
qua ce la posso fare ciò posso fare
adesso no no chiesto svenendo ho
respirato troppo sto svenendo
c'è
ma
sì se chiari action incredibile 500 ho
perso anche un braccio a litio ce l'ho
fatto ragazzi è stato tronchetto ancora
basta vedetevi soldi basta non li voglio
mille che me ne faccio di mille sono
erano 500 c'è io gli ho perso un braccio
per sé ma e c'è già chi c'era virgola
non il punto sono un [ __ ]
ma è un milione oppure non l'ho capito è
un milione
non mi interessa basta e non perdo il
braccio [ __ ] come cazzo faccia per
non ha nemmeno segnato sulla classifica
stores tosto punteggio maledizione
[ __ ] [ __ ] mi son cagato addosso e
vabbè è successo ho vinto nome era erano
erano media è allora cazzo si da vecchi
amici a perdere due braccia per 500 mi
sembra una cagata anche per 66 66 e era
tutto calcolato ragazzi il diavolo ci
perseguita conclude episodio ragazzi
spero che vi do mi sia piaciuto è stato
tragico ma veramente se vi sia piaciuto
una ragazzina sotto questo mi piace per
ogni like che mettete un braccio in più
va bene anche pace di facebook che
covano i video tratta descrizione si
esaurisce discrete ci vediamo al
prossimo vinto e ragazzi